what if penny was hiding a deep dark
secret from the guys since the very
first episode
too hard to believe well keep watching
because we're diving into a fan theory
that changes everything
if you really think about it we barely
know anything about the big bang
theory's penny who until she marries
leonard in season 9 doesn't even have a
last name she's beautiful and blonde but
that doesn't mean her supposed acting
career is going anywhere she can somehow
afford to live in the same apartment
building as several working scientists
in spite of her waitress salary you
realize penny that the technology that
went into this arm will one day make
unskilled food servers such as yourself
obsolete
really they're gonna make a robot that
spits on your hamburger
all the while her character seems to
have nothing at all in common with
leonard and his friends yet she still
spends almost all of her time hanging
out with them eating chinese food and
listening to them nerd out about
subjects she doesn't seem to grasp it
speaks to a crisis in the very
foundation of the show's premise that
these inconsistencies are never probed
let alone explained look too hard at the
character penny and based on the sheer
improbability of this one woman's
choices and traits you'll see all the
cracks that should have brought the
entire structure of the series crumbling
down
fortunately there is a fan theory that
provides an explanation for all of these
apparent plot holes and its implications
are pretty darn wild to comprehend
according to this fan theory first
posited by reddit user number theory and
picked up by screenrant it's quite
possible that penny is secretly a spy
that's right move over the americans
because chuck lori's got an entirely
different story to tell about a deep
cover agent living among her
unsuspecting marks
the theory ties into the notion that the
federal government has been spying on
sheldon and leonard ever since the
latter broke up with joyce kim a woman
who was revealed to be a north korean
spy in the episode the staircase
implementation
an upset leonard causes an explosion
that takes out the building's elevators
which may not interest local authorities
for very long but coupled with the kim
incident very well could have drawn the
attention of the federal government
aware of leonard and sheldon's knowledge
of a rocket fuel project they simply
sent penny in to monitor both men
according to the theory it sounds absurd
but it actually ties up all of the
lingering confusion about her lifestyle
think about it penny without even an
identifiable last name has been sent
into the men's lives to observe their
antics
this explains why she spends so much
time with two guys who don't share her
interests why she doesn't have any
friends of her own how she can afford an
apartment without a roommate and why
there's a lack of traction in her
so-called acting career when you were
telling kevin about your acting career
did you mention your long-running role
as waitress in a local production of the
cheesecake factory
all obvious violations of occam's razor
aside sometimes it's the explanation
that actually explains everything that's
worthy of consideration
unlike the real life big bang theory
ironically enough you can think of it as
a unified theory of penny no cops be
cool
if you're still having trouble wrapping
your head around the possibility that
penny is the spy next door then consider
this
despite penny's lack of multiple phds
the big bang theory makes it clear she's
not an idiot far from it in fact without
the slow reveal of penny's intelligence
over the course of her long character
arc would her relationship with the
objectively brilliant leonard even work
maybe just maybe she plays it all babe
in the woods whenever the boys descend
into science talk just to keep their
guard down maybe she feigns a total lack
of understanding to lure this apartment
full of useful idiots into a false sense
of security if they knew right from the
get-go that penny understood even a
fraction of what they were saying maybe
they would have been more guarded with
the details of their work her
performative ignorance provides them
with just the level of comfort they need
to spill each and every classified being
all the while if this theory is to be
believed at least penny could be
carefully recording any and all
information that may be of interest to
federal intelligence now go back and
watch the entire series from the
beginning with this new understanding
it's a totally different show that's
about it
that's the story of penny
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the big bang theory are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you